this video is going up on 421 with
today's 4/20 happy 4/20 to all you
mother-effing people out there flashback
Friday
I'm Greg that John this is Perry nerimon
number up sorry because of 4/20 no no no
no I wrote it down to everything camera
P camera follow our twitter and
instagram collider videos you've heard
of an actor called Bryan Cranston Bryan
print ah yes star why ham and some other
good things too
anyway no we're gonna watch the
Wakefield trailer today Breaking Bad
Breaking Bad never yeah I'm not checking
a text message I'm just pulling up the
photos to see who requested this line is
checking a sec sighs oh my god
leave me alone Greg stop this Dan I
matched a match guy Daniel having said
react to Bryan Cranston's new movie it's
called Wakefield I smell Oscar
nomination for him the movie looks
absolutely beautiful good luck with the
channel guys know if everything works
out okay alright alright guys my other
prize they have a third Cloverfield
moving so fast I guess this joke really
is yeah it's two trillion dollars John
yeah okay guys B Krantz that's what I
call sort of mom called
suburban life so much is the same week
after week who hasn't happy enough to
put their life on hold for a moment like
your Spanish completely Safran gardener
oh my wife's first call would be to my
office he hadn't coming in this Apothic
[Music]
she suddenly
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god LRD in there fort swatting
[Music]
whoa crazy cat lady next door I'll
become powered week you was meant to be
oh my god
power out when I expected Howard on
wakefield all directed rather sweet
chord
Robin slippery we all noticed films or
herself never know never knows on the
day and I read surely find out well guys
Perry Nemiroff that was something did
your comments are saying Oscar so he
said that is he sees snow Oscar nominee
later I would be very surprised if if
ifc films went on to win an Oscar is one
of them yeah I'm also a little surprised
when I heard nothing about this from tip
it's a it looks kind of good I didn't
know II was kind of dated good I don't
know I can't solve I'm taking it
seriously or not well it seems like it's
a bit of a drama D and more so I feel
like when we're laughing we're supposed
to laugh but I feel like when you're
feeling down and gluing all the codes to
fear I think we were supposed to last
the glass drop which we did the other
one before I can't remember exactly
what's happening but if I'm supposed to
be feeling bad for him in my last that's
when he was doing the voice of what
she's with yeah that's a little jarring
I have no idea why I am thinking of this
movie now for some reason this movie
rang the swiss army man bell in my mind
who I don't know how to exactly put that
into words but it does have that kind of
like especially when the second half
kicks in and he's like older you got
that huge beard it seems like he's just
screwing in this house for like ten
years or many many years you know I
started to get that sort of life fantasy
surreal yeah getting away from
everything it makes me think a little uh
captain fantastic too yeah that's great
one of the contemplative like life
things that had little fans feel I love
it Alan I love this movie already I have
had I had my weird fantasies of like
what if I faked my death and I was able
to witness what everyone thought
wouldn't it is beautiful whatever I
could just witness everything and they
make it seem like somebody take my death
and try to put me away when I was a
prisoner I don't nobody will ever frame
me for making my own and not exactly
what he has going on here but the idea
of a man who's you know fake that he's
like really disappeared and missing but
this is right next door the whole time
and watching the way how everyone is
like responding to him and becoming
fascinated with it and seen as a wife
moving on and going on dates and stuff
it's such a weird like out-of-body
experience in it for him
I don't know I'm always at least a
little excited watching these trailers
to see such like a strange concept you
know has a strange contents get made yes
and I like that it feels small no flan
it was like it's doing the only thing
that would make a movie like this work
and it's focus on the main character
Brian Randi what what's that our actor
two cats in a role like that the Bryan
Cranston role better remember this
character's name Henry Lee Wakefield
yeah they feel this way right yeah yeah
I'll be the real Henry Wakefield that
was meant to be a Jennifer Garner I get
a letter in that Apple exploit now yeah
I mean how's your living and homestead
affair with Bryan Cranston I will write
that rumor here I'll order now this help
us help this video go viral folks
resources doubt isn't why they split up
we are the sources I'm sure there's a
six degrees of separation I can still
not get connected to that applica
Jennifer Garner right Cranston I've met
Bryan Cranston dude yeah you can leave
your house yes okay no but I don't have
nothing yeah what you so mad
oh that's groundbreaking drama Malcolm
in the Middle
yeah really good I was really cool yeah
well I suppose at the end of this video
we have reached the conclusion of our
thoughts on a Wakefield trailer okay
before this video wraps up the parry
number on we recently launched the
patreon very
so and we've had a lot of amazing people
donate to our patreon so we've been
given a few shoutouts in there to those
who have earned her way to a shout-out
for patron of the day
Rosa Parra she donated forty five
dollars to us he wants a handwritten
thank you note and we said
abso-fucking-lutely had so you know what
I found out about Rosa she lives in
California
so postage will be real ching real cheap
or we can just get you in that we can
just visit her unexpectedly and she'll
get more than what she bargained for I
love you guys so much
project happens a hand delivered hand is
what we record wearing costumes and
we're moustaches on we're mustache on
Women's Day yeah and we could follow her
for a while yeah give it to her life
when she's left the house is like out
somewhere maybe like with friends so we
can really like you know make it a whole
morning for Rosa thank you for being a
patron LCU today subscribe to the real
reject jobs reasons Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram key social medias manages real
rejects emblem house that's right Blum
house Blum house Harry never um Islam is
on Collider video said pairing him off
like five times in this video save five
times s perry Nemiroff Perry never not
Perry number up Harry Nimrod Perry
number of that's my time yeah everyone
yes well done
Collider videos at P number off on
Twitter and Instagram and she's also
just a pure delight and she's only in
California for like a day or two
cuz she's constantly traveling breaks my
heart but she asked me out on a date I
said no you know and then and I really
and I would be all girl I thought I was
playing it cool and smart like oh I'll
reject makes her want me more not shut
the whole thing down now let's remember
all of it at
until they known as you and then they
strike up the conversation like hey why
are you following me this is kind of
creeping you're like I don't know man
way I got that in the night ever escape
good luck to you both